[Music]
the fiercest takeover battle of 2021
took place in a sector that hadn't seen
a major deal in over 20 years the
railroad industry and just like in the
board game monopoly it immediately
became clear why owning more railroads
is such an attractive prospect the saga
began in march when canadian pacific
agreed to buy smaller rival kansas city
southern for 28.9 billion dollars
including debt
the transaction would allow canadian
pacific to form a 20 000 mile network
that stretched across north america to
create the first u.s mexico canada
railroad
but canadian national a larger rival to
the two smallest players of the
so-called class 1 rail operators in the
region had other plans
in april it gate crashed canadian
pacific's bid with a 34 billion offer to
buy kansas city southern
by may it had convinced the board of the
u.s company to back its offer
but all was not well for canadian
national behind the scenes trouble
emerged soon after when one of its major
shareholders the uk activist investor
christopher hahn of tci warned it to
drop its plans or face a shareholder
revolt hong who also happened to be a
big shareholder in canadian pacific
believed u.s regulators at the surface
transportation board would take issue
with a voting trust that canadian
national planned to use for its deal
voting trusts are vehicles that allow a
buyer of an asset to immediately pay the
shareholders of the target company even
while regulators investigate the merger
proposal
during this process the companies
seeking to merge continue to be operated
independently the stb had already told
canadian national that they would take a
harder line on their voting trust plans
using a stricter criteria than what they
planned to apply to canadian pacific
han said if canadian national pressed
ahead and failed he would seek the
immediate resignation of its chief
executive
by the end of august the stb rejected
canadian nationals voting trust request
spooking its shareholders by then
canadian pacific had already returned to
the table with a fresh 31 billion dollar
takeover offer
by mid-september kansas city southern
agreed to a deal with canadian pacific
as it prevailed in the takeover battle
and in october canadian national said
chief executive jean-jacques roost who
failed to clinch the deal would leave
the company within a few months
the saga showed that unlike in monopoly
he who has the most cash doesn't always
win
you